hello everyone i'm dr umar malik and
welcome to my simplified i hope all of
you are doing well
before i start i would like to tell you
that our channel has recently crossed
900 000 subscribers and we are growing
day by day all thanks to you
i really appreciate the love and support
from you guys and we look forward to
cross more such milestones in the
upcoming future
so friends in today's video we will be
talking about the sunflower plant
scientifically known as helianthus anus
to be precise we will be talking about
the amazing health benefits of the
sunflower seeds
i'm pretty sure all of you have seen the
bright yellow flower of the sunflower
plant it's impossible to miss
the seeds are harvested from the head of
the sunflower plant
the flower head measures up to 12 inches
in diameter and one flowering head might
contain up to 2000 seeds
sunflower seeds are white but have a
tough outer shell
the shell is black and white with a
striped appearance
in many parts of the world including my
own which is india humans have been
consuming sunflower seeds since the time
immemorial in many forms
raw seeds are eaten as a portable and
easy snack
roasted seeds are sprinkled on top of
cereals cooked vegetables or salads
sunflower seeds can also be added to
breads or muffins
and oil and butter are obviously the
most common use of sunflower seeds
worldwide
well in this video we will talk about
some of the scientifically backed health
benefits of consuming sunflower seeds
so sit back relax and let me simplify it
for you
number one
sunflower seeds are densely packed with
nutrients
sunflower seeds are a wholesome food
this is because they are packed with a
good amount of healthy nutrients in
sufficient quantities
take for example just about 100 grams of
sunflower seeds contain 585 calories of
energy
mind you these are pure complex
carbohydrates which are considered as
good calories
they also contain about 8.5 grams of
fiber so just a wrist full of sunflower
seeds can meet the fiber demand of your
body
they contain about 51.5 grams of
essential fats and these are mostly
polyunsaturated and monounsaturated fats
which are known as good fats
these help in lowering your blood
cholesterol level and improve your
cardiovascular health
100 grams of sunflower seeds contain
about 20 grams of proteins
and they also contain micronutrients
such as thymine riboflavin niacin
pantothenic acid folate choline vitamin
b6 vitamin c and vitamin e
sunflower seeds also contain minerals
like calcium iron magnesium manganese
phosphorus potassium sodium and zinc
this information should be enough to
motivate you to start adding sunflower
seeds to your diet
before we proceed further in the video i
would like to take a minute to introduce
you all to yellow class
yellow class is india's biggest live and
interactive hobby learning platform
where kids can learn different hobbies
like art and craft dancing singing
cooking yoga and much more absolutely
free of cost
apart from these classes on maths
english general knowledge and logical
reasoning are also available on yellow
class
every month more than 10 lakh kids
attend various classes on yellow class
and learn various skills absolutely free
all the classes provided by yellow class
are completely free and they are
designed by professionals which are
experts in their field
special classes by celebrity mentors
like shaan ripudaman vidya malvade are
also available on yellow class
along with learning different hobbies on
yellow class kids can also win many
prizes like playstation apple ipad
bicycles amazon vouchers and much more
in february yellow class is running an
online contest where the winner can get
an apple iphone 13. in order to take
part in the contest all you have to do
is download the yellow class app using
the link given in the description box
down below and start attending the
classes
kids who will complete the above steps
will be automatically eligible for this
competition
number two sunflower seeds are good for
your heart
as i mentioned earlier sunflower seeds
are rich in fats now the word fats makes
people think about unhealthy stuff
but sunflower seeds are rich in healthy
fats including polyunsaturated fats and
monounsaturated fats
especially a compound known as linoleic
acid
linoleic acid is an essential fatty acid
it is very important because it is a
compound that relaxes blood vessels in
your body and also helps in lowering
your blood cholesterol level
this was clinically proven by a study at
harvard university
in 2014 a paper was published titled
consumption of plant seeds and
cardiovascular health epidemiologic and
clinical trial evidence
this summarized that there is
substantial evidence that increased seed
consumption including sunflower seeds is
associated with lower risk of
cardiovascular disease and type 2
diabetes
they meant that there is significant
reduction in the risk factors of heart
disease such as serum cholesterol levels
or high blood pressure which is
attributable to various components of
the sunflower seed
such as
niacin or vitamin v3 which is present in
sunflower seeds
it is an essential component of the
cholesterol pathways and it acts to
reduce the total cholesterol levels
vitamin b5 or pentothinic acid in
sunflower seeds increases hdl
which is healthy cholesterol
and it is required by the body
fiber present in the sunflower seeds
decreases the total fat absorption of
your body
magnesium which is an essential mineral
helps your blood vessels to relax and
eventually decreases the blood pressure
levels
cyanurine is an alkaloid found in the
sunflower seeds and it can lower
triglycerides and cholesterol levels
an effect that may potentially benefit
people with hyperglycemia or
hyperlipidemia
now this combined glucose and
cholesterol lowering effect of sunflower
seeds is especially important in people
with diabetes
some research like a 2012 study on
elderly females with type 2 diabetes
mellitus suggests that people who ate
sunflower seeds daily found their
fasting blood sugar reduced by up to 10
percent
but more research is required for wider
age group and better defined criteria
before sunflower seeds can be advocated
as a blood sugar lowering agent number
three sunflower seeds can boost your
immunity
sunflower seeds are packed with
essential vitamins and minerals
the most important of these for our
immunity are vitamin e
zinc and selenium
vitamin e is crucial to immune function
and helps to protect us against various
illnesses
it is a powerful antioxidant that helps
to prevent cell damage by free radicals
zinc is a key component of the immune
system and can help with the development
and maintenance of the immune cells
it also has antioxidant properties
a selenium also has natural
anti-inflammatory properties and it also
boosts the immune system to produce a
better immune response when required
this mineral is also postulated to be a
critical part of brain health
and is linked to prevention of various
neurodegenerative diseases such as
alzheimer's disease
now talking about brain health sunflower
seeds can also boost your brain function
sunflower seeds are a good source of
vitamin b6 also known as pyridoxine
this essential nutrient is important for
the synthesis of many neurotransmitters
in the brain
usually the imbalance of
neurotransmitters can lead to various
mental effects
so consumption of sunflower seeds can
restore the optimum balance
this helps to improve mood concentration
and memory
number four
sunflower seeds can reduce inflammation
in our previous videos we regularly talk
about the term inflammation
to clear a misconception inflammation
itself isn't bad it is a natural process
of our body that initiates in response
to injury or stress that occurs either
externally or internally
while in acute situations inflammation
is important for the body to control the
extent of damage and start the process
of healing and recovery
it is the chronic inflammation that is
proven to be harmful for us and chronic
inflammation is a risk factor for many
chronic diseases
one way researchers and doctors quantify
inflammation is by calculating the
levels of protein in a body known as c
reactive protein in short crp
increased crp levels in your body are a
signal for higher risk of inflammation
which is directly linked to the heart
disease and diabetes
a 2006 research titled nut and seed
consumption and inflammatory markers
attempted to find a relation between
consumption of seeds and nuts including
sunflower seeds and markers of
inflammation such as levels of crp
interleukin 6 and fibrinogen
they found that frequent nut and seed
consumption including sunflower seeds
was associated with lower levels of
inflammatory markers including crp
this also explained the association of
nut consumption with lower risk of
cardiovascular disease and diabetes
number five sunflower seeds are great
for pregnant females
sunflower seeds contain zinc folate and
vitamin e
these are all important nutrients for a
fetus to grow
so if you're trying to have a baby or
you are pregnant
or you're just someone following a
healthy diet sunflower seeds have
something for everyone
folate is a micronutrient with a very
important role in a developing baby
adequate folate levels are required for
the placenta to grow and remain healthy
also also folate is important for the
baby's brain and nervous system to grow
to its full potential folate deficiency
has been linked to terrible outcomes
such as spina bifida
zinc present in the sunflower seeds is
also important for the baby's pancreas
to produce insulin and other vital
enzymes
vitamin e present in these seeds is
essential for the fetus
it helps the muscles grow and also
supports the red blood cells which do
all the hard work of transporting vital
oxygen to each and every part of the
developing fetus
but wait
there's another benefit of sunflower
seeds
the healthy fatty acid the zinc and the
vitamin e gives you healthier skin
our skin is the first line of defense
against lethal diseases
it suffers from various external
destructive forces and regenerates
itself to keep the barrier strong
the essential fatty acids such as oleic
and linoleic acid found in the sunflower
seeds help prevent skin diseases
these compounds also help with the wound
healing and preventing scarring
so if you want a glowing complexion give
them a try
antibacterial and antifungal properties
of sunflower seeds also prevent
infections
thus keeping our skin clear
additionally zinc and vitamin e protect
the skin against uv damage and
accelerate skin regeneration
before i go there are some facts you
should be careful of
here are some potential side effects of
sunflower seeds
eating too many sulfur seeds can make
you vomit cause stomach ache and lead to
constipation
do not consume more than recommended
if you are allergic to some seeds
eating sunflower seeds can cause
vomiting rashes on the skin breathing
problems like wheezing or struggling to
breathe
sunflower seeds are high in calories
eating too many can lead to weight gain
sunflower seeds contain traces of
cadmium which are not good for our
kidneys so
moderate its consumption
also contaminated sprouts seeds can lead
to bacterial infections of the gut
as always it is important to wash your
hands before eating them
download the yellow class app now and
start your learning journey today well
friends with this we come to the end of
this video
i hope i have given you some new and
exciting facts and knowledge
if you liked today's video don't forget
to share it with your friends and family
if you are new to our channel consider
subscribing if you liked our content
we at med simplified always appreciate
your support and feedback
consider becoming a member of our
youtube channel or our patreon community
to support our channel
you can find us on instagram
search for med simplified on instagram
we post daily facts medical tidbits and
posts that will brighten your day
the links are in the description box
down below
as always take care and i'll see you in
the next one